[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the Daily Express columnist and
broadcaster Carol Malone and the Belfast
Telegraph columnist Alison Morris
they'll be with us from now right up
until just before midnight so let's see
what's coming up on the front pages for
you now
well the Metro leads with water UK
saying they'll subsidize 10 billion
pounds of improvements to the nation's
waterways but customers will be made to
paper it in the end the paper calls it a
dirty trick
the financial times reports on BT's
plans to cut 55 000 jobs which would
amount to 42 percent of its Workforce
some of whom could be replaced by AI
technology
according to the eye the government is
exploring whether it may be necessary to
bring in laws to stop companies doing
just that
the mail throws ahead to a possible AI
jobs blood bar
reporting from the G7 meeting the
guardian has news of fresh British
sanctions against Russia over the war in
Ukraine
the express has wished you soon at
backing himself to win the next general
election
UK's Reliance on foreign nurses is at a
critical level writes the times
the drive to Net Zero will add an
estimated 120 pounds to energy bills
reports the telegraph
The Mirror Has the story of a
six-year-old boy who survived a dog
attack
and on a much different note the star
Ponders the appeal or otherwise of why
front Underpants
and a reminder that by scaling the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Carol
Malone and Allison Morris welcome to
both of you let's start with the Metro
front page and this 10 billion pounds as
they say over dirty dirty tricks Carol
explain
this is as big the cost it's good it's
going to be invested Borrowed by the
water companies because they have been
dumping tons and tons of sewage raw
sewage into all rivers and seas I mean
there's some of the figures for the
amounts that they were dumping was
something like
865 tons a day or something and it's
just astonishing
Kelly who was the boss of um water UK
she
that with this half-hearted apology and
she said um well sorry we didn't act
sooner to fix this but hey we get it I
mean you get it it's yeah this is raw
sewage pumped into our water which
contains bacterias and viruses it
affects the fish light it affects all
sorts of other ecosystems in our Waters
and and yeah we paid for this service
I've done that many mine is Ken's water
in London it's seems that I pay a
fortune every year for water and now
they want you to pay again because this
10 billion pounds that they're borrowing
to fix their Antiquated Victorian
systems is going to come out of our
pockets over the next 50 to 100 years it
seems astonishing when you know the
shareholders Julian and these companies
on average every year they get paid 2
billion quid systems of a privatized 30
years ago last year I think the industry
paid 1.4 billion to shells but generally
it's an average of 2 billion quid why
isn't the money but these repairs and
what need to be done why isn't it coming
out of the Year's bonuses of the
shareholders profits why are we having
to twice but what was already a shoddy
service yes the water UK is saying that
they have apologized for the 300 000 uh
sewage dumps in rivers and that whatever
customers will will have to pay will be
modest increments uh Alison is that is
that enough
well it don't interest me they they
cooked um fergal Sharkey the former
singer of the undertones he's a big
campaigner on this issue a month from
May part of the world and he said why
should why should customers have to pay
for their incompetence and I think
that's how most customers would see it
it's also as Carl said it's completely
not really filthy there should be held
in paint for what they've done the
environmental damage they've caused
um and it just made me glad that during
lockdown when everyone had decided that
there were going to be called swimmers
and jump into freezing water that I
stayed safely at home with a glass of
wine and didn't partake in that
particular Pastime now that we know how
much sewage was being pumped into the
waterways
yes you were wise not to to jump in
Alison let's move on to the Telegraph
and this Net Zero Drive will add 120
pounds to energy bills is that a price
worth paying Carol
Scott we knew how much it was going to
cost householders we knew it was gonna
it was gonna hit Arbors I don't know if
it's a price worth paying quite now not
at this moment in time when people are
already struggling to pay their energy
bills you know we're hearing now that
that in Council houses and Council
properties their their bills are going
to increase by 300 how on Earth can
people afford a rise of another 120
pounds a year it is astonishing you know
people have had to be compensated by the
government this year to the tune of
something I think it's about three grand
per household to help cope with with all
the energy bills how are they going to
cope with law you know I get the drive
to NetZero I understand it and that and
I know that you know I understand the
problems of climate change but I think
you know you have to look at the lives
people are living now and they're pretty
grim and there's there's no let up to
these energy bills we're told that might
be a little bit cheaper by the summer
but a little bit cheaper as not much use
when you you know the bills have gone up
by one to 100 for a lot of people so I
think this is this is not a price worth
paying at this moment in time yes and
it's to defund uh the development of
hydrogen gas under the government's net
zero plans but but in the article it's
saying that this would apply despite the
fact that hydrogen is expected to play
only a limited role in home heating with
the uh the government the main
replacement for for
um
gas boilers expected to be heat pumps so
as Carol was saying Allison is is this
unnecessary at this point
I do say it's very important and we know
it's very important that we protect the
the planet from for our future
Generations but the issue is that we are
in a cost of living crisis and um energy
costs but not massively in the last year
and some people I know people who own
businesses who have had to close their
doors as a result of the increased
energy cost they just couldn't afford to
pay anymore
um and so if we could manage to get
those costs back down again if there
could maybe be a cap on the profits that
a lot of those big fossil fuel companies
make so that the price of of fuel can be
kept low I think if you could do that
well then it's worth investing this
money for the long-term future but as
you said it doesn't seem that this is a
plan that's going to completely not
really fix our environmental problems it
seems just a very small part of that and
what I'd really like to see is something
that is not just a longer term plan but
something that's going to make a massive
difference I mean we do we know we rely
too heavily on fossil fuels you know
that's not a secret but there does need
to be a way to phase this out so that
people kind of forward to hate and like
their homes and right now people are
just about managing to do that are
struggling around the bread line relying
on food banks and to say to them another
120 pound a year you know that is the
difference between them being able to
turn their heating on in the winter or
not
yes uh the absolutely right let's move
on to the ft and this is quite a big
story today BT plans to Cull 55
000 jobs this decade
um roughly around I think 10 000 uh
being attributed or would be replaced by
AI technology
um something to fear Carol or not
yeah I think it is this is this is a
gonna be 42 of BT's Workforce it's the
most aggressive cull since the company
was privatized back in the 80s
um and this is the CEO of BT is saying
you know this is going to bring some
significant advances well yes it is for
the people that get a fire and whose
lives are going to wreck you know the
thing is AI I I don't pretend to
understand everything that it means but
what I feel is that it's coming too fast
and too hard and it's one of the reasons
why Rishi sunak at the G7 today has
called for
um AI to be regulated because he is
saying it's all happening so yeah and I
think besides us now we've also come out
and said they want rules put in place to
protect Society to protect political
systems and also literally to protect
human life now you know this this
announcement by BT is is terrified for
every imagine how unsettling that is if
you if you work for boutine it comes hot
on the heels of uh vodafone's decision a
couple of days ago to acts
um was 11 000 jobs
Vodafone so very unsettling for all
these people in these industries now
it's supposed to be great technological
advances but what does it actually mean
for people and humanity and and I don't
think we know that yet so these
regulations that sunak is calling for I
think have to be put in place and pretty
soon yeah I mean it's leading to a lot
of uh insecurity as you describe but the
mail their headline AI jobs bloodbath
Allison
yeah I mean right now there's a sort of
Scandal in Ireland about uh the Irish
Times which is always paraded itself on
being the pepper of record carried an
opinion piece by someone calling
themselves Adriana Cortez who said that
um she was from Ecuador and that the
Reliance of faked ham by Irish women was
cultural appropriation and the chief
found it offensive and this obviously
acted as clickbait and there was lots of
comments on it but without even it was
gone and it turned out that if some
student who had created this and AI
centered in and the Irish Times had
carried it and they had to apologize to
the readers for the deception because it
clearly wasn't real you know it was
completely made up the writer was made
up this person did not exist and where
that can be quite funny and quite
humorous when you think about it imagine
in the deeper you know repercussions of
that in the long term the sort of fake
news element if people use that for much
more nefarious purposes than what we
have seen so far and we're having an
election here today in Northern Ireland
local government election but during our
Assembly Election last year two very
young female Cowans it's both had deep
fit porn films spread claiming they were
the ham and it wasn't it was completely
faked using that kind of technology and
so we need to be really careful in terms
of what this does to people's lives but
also the implications it can have
because you know we talk a lot about
making sure that you sort of double
source that your news is coming from
correct the the correct sources and that
it has been checked and that it is
accurate but imagine the repercussions
if you know AI was used widespread used
in in the media could you know we could
be getting in this situation especially
when it comes to elections and things
like that where it could be used for all
the wrong reasons yes there has been
some concern about the American
elections forthcoming America elections
and the creator of jat uh chat GPT
um
gave a report to Congress saying that
they wanted to be regulated they wanted
more regulation and that does seem to be
the area that needs to be investigated
how to to control AI that we clearly
don't understand the full extent of as
yet Carol
I mean imagine how scary it is this is a
new phenomenon that we don't know what
it's capable of and there are no
controls over it you know as Addison
just said there you know you can use it
to read news to rig the news agenda you
could use it to rig elections it's
terrifying and and yet we are using it
and employing it something that we don't
actually understand I was listening I
watched um as a scientists the other day
try to explain it I swear to God I
watched for half an hour and I wasn't
much the wiser and he was having
problems and he was saying that people
like him don't fully get what it's
capable of so how the hell are we
supposed to and how are we supposed to
regulate something we don't understand
it's scary it is quite uh terrifying
Allison DBI they're saying that there's
been a dramatic shift in tone and the UK
is now focusing on the threats posed by
Ai and as well as the opportunities and
this comes as the British government is
pushing for regulations to
quote protect Humanity against the
potential dangers
yeah and the TV are dangerous and you
know we know the prime minister is now
at the j7 and these are kind of the kind
of things that will clearly be discussed
as as a as part of that because we don't
know are there security implications you
know is does this pose a threat in the
wrong hands to National Security what
other purposes can it be used for and
the fact is that you know this
technology has moved so fast I mean
um just a few days ago someone had told
me an AI generated story where they had
put you know my name
um and said write you know 800 words in
this day love and I it was pretty
accurate the way it came out in terms of
the state of writing from my newspaper
and I did it within minutes you know you
could actually see it working its way
through it and and there's something
like that could seemed you know I
suppose like a bit of a partner game but
when you think about the consequences of
that in the long term in terms of
National Security in terms of politics
in terms of how we live our lives and
also in terms of jobs and people rely on
it we did have a period of automation
where people lost a lot of those
industry jobs and were replaced by
Machinery but other jobs were created I
can't say that if jobs are replaced by
AI what other jobs are we creating for
the the people who are going to lose
lose their employment as a result